speech along with me if you wish
as chairman of the house health human
services and elderly affairs committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing and executive
session please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and that the public has access to listen
contemporaneously and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform
or by telephone all necessary and
access information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and with
rsa 91 a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
3600 or email
h c s at
l e g dot state
dot nh dot u s in the event the public
as a whole is unable to access
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
christina daya is the staff member
assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by
roll call vote we will start the meeting
by taking
a roll call attendance when each member
states his or her presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know
law would the clerk please call the
on a role
in that case
here we go
this is in a different order than you're
probably used to
dennis acton i'm here and i'm alone in
the room
jerry cannon i'm here in somersworth and
i'm
alone in my home mia cushman present
in the committee room beth folsom
betty gay
[Music]
uh please hang on one second hello
uh madame clark
we are in 301
[Music]
she is nikki kelsey
bill king
jerry kanerk
here in my study in freedom and uh
i'm alone in the room but my wife is in
the house elsewhere
jim kofalt i am here in my home office
in wilton
and uh there are other people in the
house not in the room
jim mckay
charlie mcmahon
i have seen you
okay i thought i saw him gary merchant
[Music]
here in claremont in my home and there's
my wife is somewhere else in the house
bill meltzer karen brookfield and my
wife is somewhere in the house
francis hello i'm here in nashua
alone in my living room mark pearson
is here in the lob jeff soloway
uh president in lee new hampshire in my
home office
and i am alone joe shapiro
present in my home office in keene
alone kendall snow
lucy webber uh present in
concord alone uh except that there are
carpenters immediately outside the house
carpenters they've only just begun
they have only just begun and i
fervently hope they will finish
soon
uh president uh i'm here in my uh study
uh in beau and i'm alone
now we're gonna do a second run through
since people found
us uh folsom
[Music]
and betty gay president finally
and nikki kelsey here in yellow and bill
king
here at the lb and the only one i'm
missing
the only two i'm missing is charlie
mcmahon
and ken snow
and i promise not to be so informal the
rest of me
and mr chair i'm going to leave now to
go to my other meeting i'll be back
before 10 i hope
thank you okay
i am opening the hearing on senate bill
relative to the controlled drug
prescription health
and safety program with senator bob
gaida
as the principal sponsor senator geider
would you introduce your bill to us
please
thank you honourable chairman pearson
and members of the house health and
human services committee
for the record i'm bob gaida state
senator for district 2
and prime sponsor senate bill 45.
senator 45 as amended by the senate add
some key data sharing provisions to the
prescription drug monitoring program or
pdmp
specifically in section 1 roman 4 we add
medical reconciliation
to the definition of services delivered
by a dispenser
under cms the definition of the term
medical reconciliation means quote
the process of identifying the most
accurate list of all medications that
the patient is taking including name
dosage frequency and route by comparing
the medical record to an external list
of medications obtained from a patient
hospital or other provider under roman
four
the bill adds one additional category
parent f
to those excluded from being considered
as dispensers
specifically a practitioner who neither
prescribes nor dispenses
and who is not actively working as a
pharmacist with a new hampshire licensed
pharmacy licensed
under rsa 318 or new hampshire
healthcare facility licensed under rsa
what this does is to exclude
non-practicing professionals
from gaining access to pdmp data
in section four the bill adds under
parent four
the ability of pharmacy nursing
physician
licensing and other participating boards
to use pdmp data
and treating impaired members of their
professions
at this point i feel it's important to
speak why the original bill
uh was amended by the senate it was
amended to delete any references to the
pdmp data sharing program with
the department of health and human
services given that the pdmp
is being moved from oplc the office of
professional licensure and certification
to dhhs though this makes administrative
sense
the senate had several concerns with the
move
first dhhs seeks to use pdmp data for
public health programs and analyses
but the program was never intended to be
used for public health purposes
it was intended to identify individuals
not to analyze populations
any such potential expansion of the
program's intent merits careful scrutiny
by this legislature
prior to its implementation and will be
the subject of future legislation
second the legislature's privacy mandate
regarding use of pdmp data was clear and
unambiguous
and was underscored by the public's
overwhelming support for for the 2018
cacr
that added article 2b to our new
hampshire constitution
prioritizing our personal privacy as a
constitutional matter
clearly data privacy is of permanent
importance to the people of new
hampshire
unfortunately a dhhs attempt to provide
pdmp data to the federal government to
garner grant funding was discovered
and prompted the senate mindful of the
obvious data privacy concerns
to remove dhhs data sharing provisions
from this bill
and to address it in separate
legislation this concludes my testimony
on senate bill 45 i ask for your
committee support for this bill
to improve the utility of the pdmp while
scrupulously maintaining the privacy of
its data
and i'm happy to answer any questions mr
chairman
any questions for the senator
representative marsh yes thank you
senator for coming before us today can
you hear me
i can hear you
given that uh
now i can't hear you now sir
sorry
feedback in the background
are we better now we're better now okay
good uh given that
house bill 2 section 39 repeals the
section of why that is filled with
demand
and given that these data sharing
provisions are really quite important
uh do you have any feelings about
uh perhaps you're introducing this
language to house bill 2
is an amendment so it goes to rsa 146 a
uh as uh the uh obedient reasons for the
uh they move to that section of
the statutes and having our committee
retain this bill so that you can work
with us to fix any issues that were made
after the passing of the blessing i i'm
amenable to whatever gets the job done
representative and uh as we all know the
vaguers of the political process can
sometimes be confounding and frustrating
but i'm happy to uh
you know to do whatever it takes to get
this
into legislation it's good legislation
that needs to happen
uh that will enable for example uh the
nursing profession
uh the licensing boards for nursing
doctors and so forth
to assist those members of their
professions that are struggling with
drug abuse or misuse so again
i think it's an important an important
addition and whatever it takes to get it
there
i'd be happy to go with
thank you i agree with you and i
appreciate your flexibility because we
do have that issue with you
does anyone else have a question for
senator guida
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
i have to reveal my total ignorance on
this it sounds like
in your explanation that we are trying
to protect
people who should not be who are
drug dependent and yet the other
issue seems to be we're protecting
people's private medical privacy
could you clarify the intent of this
rule
of this law and how it how it somehow
can be manipulated so that data can be
shared
thank you for the question uh
representative so
currently uh and i would suspect there
may be others that will testify
more in depth to this but currently
what the purpose of this legislation is
is to
enable hospitals and doctors
to incorporate this data into their
electronic health records of individual
patients that they're seeing
all right uh there's also a financial
uh matter that we are eligible for
additional federal funding for medicaid
uh by enabling by enacting this
legislation uh for the purposes of pdmp
uh the data there's a study done in 19
i'm sorry in 2018
by the new england journal of medicine
that conclusively showed that the
uh the use of this pdnp
um facility
when combined with uh expedited
clinical access provides better outcomes
all the way around um and so
again we are protecting the patient's
privacy we are enabling the patient's
providers uh the doctors and and aprns
and and
and ils professionals to
access this data electronically um
automatically but still with the
protections that are both hipaa provided
by the provider the doctor in the office
so and also
holding responsible anyone that has
access to the data
any further questions representative
weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question
i'm this is really rather a process
question and it's perhaps
is better reserved for our executive
session but i
i want to know your thoughts on it
do you join me in thinking that it is
really better to keep policy matters
that do not
have a financial implication
out of the budget and the trailer bill
rather than enacting
rather than sliding them into the budget
or the trailer bill um
because they are policy and not having
to do with the actual budget
that's an excellent question and one
which i deal with on senate finance
starting yesterday i would again i would
be amenable to whatever gets the job
done this is not a financial implication
uh bill in any sense
but the the medical profession the
hospitals
uh the pharmacies are all looking for
this ability
uh to uh electronically access
um uh with with
significantly less work by the accessor
there was a concerted effort to access
the database
um and every access provi takes a
physical action
this would provide electronics uh i i
don't have a concern
as to putting it in trailer bill
or putting it as separate legislation
my concern is getting the getting the
job done so that these folks can
can use that pdmp to better uh treat
identify and treat uh patients who are
in fact
substance misusing well i understand the
the urgency of the concern and thank you
very much for the question for the
answer
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman i think
representative
woods has had his hands up for quite a
long time but
i'll go first i guess
thank you senator for taking my question
i am wondering
if in the process of incorporating
results into patient records if there's
some kind of
explicit consent but from the patient
for doing so
that was discussed and in fact there's
notification provided
in the doctor's office
there's no notification currently given
when they access it now
and in fact if i'm not mistaken it's
required that medical professionals do
this um
perhaps one of the medical doctors on
the on the committee might better
clarify that um
[Music]
but i i again it's not produced now as
as
you know did you are you aware of the
fact that we're curing this this is uh
it's a policy that's in place as we
speak
thank you and if i might the data is
then
used anyway by the medical professionals
i don't see that as a concern at this
point thank you
representative woods uh thank you mr
chair um
a quick question first to you are you
looking for my
visual hand or the raised hand uh
electronically
i'm looking for representative marsha's
queue
all right
and thank you senator for taking my
question um
first of all uh uh having been a
orthopedic surgeon for many years uh
this
uh process uh were fully in place when i
was
actually taking trauma call uh would
have been
a great assist for me
getting phone calls for prescriptions on
the weekend
my question uh is i have a little bit of
concern because
perhaps because i don't understand the
difference between the front end
and the back end of this process the
front end being
on page 1 line 26
through 28 the electronic health record
keeping system owner or license holder
shall be responsible for ensuring that
only authorized individuals
have access to the program information
i'm assuming that's uh individuals in uh
say
if i were in my office uh or in the
hospital
um so on the back end uh the pdpm
um how do they know that that's a
designated individual
does each individual on the front end
have a code
that has to be um designated to that
individual
and then registered on the back end uh
with a uh pdpm uh
how is that because uh otherwise an
individual
in my office may say oh well uh aunt
susie uh just
um i went to the hall i wonder what
medication she's on
and then tickle that in through the
office
into the pdpm so is there a
how does that functionally work from the
front end to the back end
for security purposes
the only access uh
only people that are registered by the
office that's using the pdmp system
are authorized to access that data
so they're specifically named yeah
they're specifically named does the pdpm
know that by code
i don't know the answer to that i don't
know the answer to that
okay well thank you
dr strength for the department is on the
call and signed up to testify he may be
able to answer that question later
well he could answer that now if he
wishes
to call on him yes
[Music]
dr um this
is initially for the purpose of
answering
um representative dr wood's question if
you can
can you hear me yes so
uh thank you for that question
representative woods
so right now in order to access data
through the pdmp
one has to be registered and
given login data which typically
consists of an email address
and a password that's how i access the
program
as an emergency physician if i were in
an office based practice
we likely would have other office staff
such as a nurse
or a clerical staff who would
sort of be teeing up the patients uh for
the day's visits and they can access
the data to have that information
available when i go in to see the
patient but they must be
registered under the name of a surrogate
me for example
and they are given individual specific
access data so when they go into
up the day's patients an electronic
footprint is left
so that the program managers can
actually go in and see who
accessed that data that would
specifically prevent
me for example if i were snooping and
looking to see
what you might have had prescribed or
the governor would have prescribed
if i were foolish enough to do that it
would leave an electronic footprint
and if that information were
inappropriately disclosed
it could it could easily be determined
who had uh done that
illegally uh thank you dr strang
i know that was the case for general
electronic medical records
i didn't know if it had carried over uh
to this
uh program as well thank you yes it has
further questions for senator geider
and representative merchant is this for
senator guyton
thank you senator for taking my question
um and
it actually goes to senator probably
david dr strang
in regards to the database i understand
that the patient can have
access to find out who's been accessing
their data within the database within
within the program itself so there are
footprints within a database that a
patient
can ascertain and find out
once that data leaves that database how
does a patient then
access inside of a healthcare entity
who has had access to their prescription
information
because no longer is going to be within
the confines of the
prescription drug program database now
it's into another database
how does the patient know that someone's
been tampering with
looking and snooping into their records
over there regards to their controlled
drugs
uh yeah i not sorry agree that it goes
into another database it goes into an
electronic health record
the access to which i'm sure is
controlled by the physician
the office perhaps the office manager so
i think that you know the disclosure of
that data
is going to require access to it and
that would be fairly easy to trace
follow-up follow-up thank you senator
gutter for the
for the answer um since it's leaving one
database is going to health record which
is really another database
electronically
would it be wise to have the patient
have sort of written consent
because then we're moving physically the
data from one database to another
database
so the patient's aware the fact that
it's leaving the confines of one
program and going into another
electronic health record that they are
actually giving their consent
i i i believe that
i don't have a problem with that but
again i would think the medical
professionals might uh
might weigh in on on the effect that
that has
potential chilling effect uh of
discovering a person that is misusing
um and so the notice is notice is given
in the doctor's offices that's a
requirement of the statute
uh that you're that your pdmp
you're being researched on the pdmp
basically uh but if you were to require
people that are abusing
to consent in writing to discovery of
their
pharmaceutical history if you will
you're going to have a significant
chilling effect on the very purpose for
this
for this program i know that we had
discussions about that
and again at some point we have to trust
that the doctor's offices and hospitals
are going to be trustworthy
again everyone that accesses that data
is by name identified
anytime they access it so again it's
easy to trace
certainly to an office in which case a
liability could be
assigned for a breach
representative
thank you thank you for giving me
permission thank you for taking my
question
i'm not sure who's wants to answer this
it sounds like we do have a system of
protection
so that there's a record of who accesses
information
and now i just like to get down to the
fine point of
does the person in the office the
doctor's
office have a different id
from the doctor himself or not doctor
whoever the practitioner is
um so is you know that's a
great comfort to me that there is a
record
but like you're saying somebody might
want to know
how aunt susie was doing uh
so does it say the person who accesses
you know the office staff
or does it just say the
office thank you for the question
uh each person that's granted i want to
say the term is licensee but i'm not
sure that's the right term but each
person that's
granted access is individually
identified with their own
unique password so it's specific to
who access the database for what patient
at what time and
uh and very traceable
thank you so that that means
that the person the staff person in the
office has their own identity
that's correct thank you
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman
thank you senator for taking my question
i i was wondering so is this for all
medications or only controlled
substances
yeah it's not all medications it's it's
controlled substances i think schedule
two through four i think is the
appropriate terminology
uh narcotics yeah yeah follow up
um can you clarify the limits that will
be placed on
department of health and human services
access to this
and are there any other government
entities that could access this
currently there there is no access by
dhhs
i chaired a working group here i'm going
to say two maybe three summers ago
in which we got all the stakeholders
together and we started working
you know towards a massive change to
provide massive access to a dhhs and it
just got to be too cumbersome so we've
broken it into bite-sized chunks if you
will
right now the hhs cannot access that
data
and again that'll be the subject of
separate legislation that we've very
carefully scrutinized because again
this was never intended to be used as a
database for public health
uh um uh analysis of populations
it was intended as an individual um you
know assist to individuals
by individual doctors or individual uh
medical professionals
uh that transition or that expansion is
one we have to watch with great care
again given the mandate for privacy that
was the initial legislation that
established pdmp the concerns for
maintaining that privacy and of course
the recent constitutional amendment
thank you any other questions for
senator guidance
one more representative gay we don't
want to keep you from the fun of working
on the budget
oh do please yes
thank you should i ask a really long
question no
no okay um okay it sounds like
that we have we are building in all
these protections thank goodness
but we are still going to access some of
this information
to benefit from federal money
do i understand that correctly no
the the benefit the federal money would
be an ancillary benefit
it's not we're not doing this for that
purpose doing this to enable the medical
professionals
to streamline uh safely uh
their functionality in their offices and
in the hospitals
uh emergency rooms or whatever and so
it would be an ancillary benefit it's
not required this program is fully
funded
uh under the state budget so uh you know
if we wanted to
go after medicaid funds for medicaid
people
uh for the four uh folks that treat them
that's a possibility it's certainly not
a it's not a driver in this legislation
follow up representative weber
representative weber working on finding
the unmute button sir
um i believe representative cushman had
a follow-up
oh i got my phone she got her follow-up
thank you okay
thank you um i i just wanted to be sure
to to clarify is it not
the overarching purpose
of this entire legislation
that we want to ensure
that controlled substances are not being
misused
and the purpose of the legislation that
we have before us
now that was the existing legislation
and that the purpose
of the legislation that we have before
and now
is to streamline the process for
professionals who were having to make
really
lengthy and uh cumbersome inquiry
so we are hoping to get ourselves to a
point of of somewhat more streamlined
questioning of the database is that
correct
that is a good assessment representative
thank you sir
seeing no other
hands thank you senator guida go have
fun
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee uh but before you do
i believe you were reading uh a prepared
uh presentation to us i know you're very
good at speaking but that was
really good to the level of you had to
be reading some of it
so could we have copies of it i've
already instructed griffin my assistant
to send it to all members of the
committee it may already be in your
inboxes
we have it already thank you very much
mr chairman thank you senator and now
the
chair would like to bring back dr david
strang to make
your presentation of anything you wish
to tell us
well thank you very much good morning mr
chairman and members of the committee
my name is dr david strang i am an
emergency physician and chairman of the
advisory council for the state's
pdmp the program to which this bill
applies
i want to be clear though that the
council has not met since this bill was
modified to its latest version so i am
not here to relate a formal
recommendation from the advisory council
on sb45 that being said though in prior
meetings there was clear support from
the council members for the concept
of integration between the pdmp and
electronic health records
also known as ehrs in my professional
opinion
this integration is the most important
part of this bill
currently in order to access pdmp data
for a patient that i'm treating in the
er
i have to leave the ehr go to the
desktop
click on a web browser such as google
type in new hampshire prescription drug
monitoring program
hope that the search brings up the login
page for the pdmp
if not i have to navigate to the login
page
type in my email address and my password
which
i remember because i use the program
enough but others
might not then i have to navigate to the
patient information page by now i've
forgotten the patient's name and date of
birth which is the minimum
data that you have to put in so i have
to put that information
in and then and only then can i access
data
for that patient i think you can
understand that's a lengthy process that
might deter
many from using the program this bill
would allow
integration such that all i would have
to do while
in the ehr for a specific patient is to
click the pdmp link
and the ehr would automatically connect
me to the pdmp for that patient
and that patient only this bill would
streamline
the process tremendously resulting in
greater usage of the program
and adding greater safety to the process
of controlled substance prescribing
after all that's what this program is
all about this bill doesn't allow
greater access
in fact some of the other housekeeping
language such as in lines 14 through 16
on page one
actually closes loopholes that might
allow inappropriate access from retired
practitioners
so i thank you for your consideration
this morning and respectfully ask that
you support this legislation
and i will be happy to answer any
questions that you might have for me
today
any questions for dr stratt
no seeing none thank you so much for
your testimony
thank you very much and the last person
we have uh
signed up to speak is our friend
paula minihan
[Music]
from the new hampshire hospital
association
can you hear me good morning
representative can you hear me now
okay great thank you um good morning
members of the committee my name is
paula minihan senior vice president
state government relations for the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals
the hospital association does support
senate bill 45
and we i am specifically testifying on
um actually paragraphs two and three
which um represent senator gaida
um and dr strang have um
been very clear in explaining that um
so but i want to just thank senator
gaida
he did sponsor a very similar piece of
legislation senate bill
676 last year but unfortunately due to
the
pandemic impacting the legislative
process it did not move forward
as dr strang has indicated
this program what we really are trying
to do is just to
create that interface and it's the emr
pdmp in
interface that's really what this
legislation does it is not
changing as dr strang said the program
the underlying program which has been in
effect for years um and is a very
important tool for practitioners but we
are just trying to
to eliminate actually the manual process
that dr strang
explained and is really problematic
because it adds a lot of complexity and
unnecessary administrative burden and
this is actually a much
better um way to to ensure
that the data is getting into the
individual's
emr um electronic medical record
so that's really what that does and as
doc senator
gaida explained we did have a lot of
discussion when this
original bill was introduced a couple
years ago
time time passes quickly but i think it
was actually when we had that discussion
it was either the summer of 18 or the
summer of 19
when we had that stakeholder group and
we talked about
protecting the patients making sure that
they understand
the data and making sure obviously that
they have hipaa projections which of
course they do
so we added paragraph three
to ensure that there is the
confidentiality component
um that was raised by some of the
senators um
prior to um this getting um
not getting through last year so that's
really
my testimony i have submitted some
testimony
written testimony that you i believe
have hap
i'm happy to answer any questions i
understand representative marsha's point
relative to the budget and again i will
reiterate what
senator guida said this is very
important legislation
we really need this to um to pass
but we will um what however
the best process for getting it into
statute is
if it needs to go through the budget
process um if
because of the change in the statute if
in fact
the budget passes and the program does
move over to dhhs
i understand a different statute
potentially would need to be
modified so whatever i i um
trust that we will um follow that
process we just need to um we really are
asking that this
this process be actually turned put into
the
statue so thank you so much thank you
any questions for ms minneham
seeing none thank you so much for your
testimony
thank you i have no one else on the list
of people who signed up in time
to testify
and there's no hands up so i am going to
all right mr courtney
uh good morning mr
all right i apologize um good morning mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is lindsay corny i'm the executive
director of the office of professional
licensure and certification
i apologize i wasn't able to register on
time
but oplc is the agency that administers
the pdmp and so i wanted to offer my
support of this bill and be available to
answer any questions
if you have them as as previously
discussed at length section 2 would
permit the office to integrate the pdmp
with electronic health systems across
the state
as dr strang mentioned one of the most
cited barriers to use of the pdmp
by practitioners is that it interrupts
workflow practitioners must step present
leave the ehr to query a separate portal
which obviously takes additional time
and it's been cited as a reason for for
non-use of the pdnp
by integrating the new hampshire pd p
with ehr systems as other states have
done
across the country new hampshire would
promote the use of pdmp by practitioners
and dispensers by eliminating this
barrier
and providing ease of access within an
established workflow
um so obviously given the public health
crisis currently impacting our state
which is the opioid epidemic that
remains
oplc supports this legislation and
requests your support as well
that's all i have for comments but i'm
happy to answer any questions if you
have
if you have any regarding the program or
this piece of legislation
any questions
good morning and the meeting welcomes
representative kendall snow to the lobby
all right seeing no more questions and
uh
i am now going to close the hearing on
house bill
uh 45 senate bill 45 and
open an exec session on the same
time representative marsha you had made
a suggestion about the possibility
of retaining it um my concern mr
chairman
is uh if he passed this bill and it's
immediately repealed
by her provisions for the budget
accomplished really very much um
if we retain the bill um then
the senate
or something needs to be fixed we would
immediately have this kind of hand as a
vehicle
to then put it into whichever statute
the pdmp
ends up in the fall of the budget still
so and that would happen much faster
than it would happen if we could
introduce a new build next fall
so i i think the best thing as far as
getting this in place
the fastest would be for us to retain
the world at this point in time
i'm confused by the logic
of um
representative marsh so i'm just trying
to untangle
procedure here um it seems to me
that if we decide this is a good bill
and i certainly
think it is and we pass it
all we're doing is adopting a committee
recommendation
nothing happens with the committee
recommendation until the next time the
house
meets at which point which i'm told
isn't going to be until for quite some
time the budget
doesn't have any effect on this
legislation whatsoever
until the governor actually signs the
budget into law
so it seems to me that there is
no reason why we could not pass
this um recommend this as ought to pass
uh send that to the house
as our recommendation so that
it is very clear what our position as a
committee
is on the legislation if if
if that is the committee's uh position
i'm making
assumptions and then at that time we can
either table it in the house if if
we know that it it has arrived at a
destination that's
agreeable to everybody or we can pass
the legislation
uh knowing that there will have to be
committees of conference and other sorts
of things
um or or that it could simply be held
either by the president of the senate or
the
speaker of the house until such time as
the budget had been
resolved and we would have it in reserve
so i'm i'm wondering if it doesn't make
more sense to
pass it if that's the will of the
committee on on the action on the bill
and then allow further steps later on in
the process and i would
if if i have lost sight of the ball
somewhere i would
welcome somebody explaining to me how
is representative it currently part of
part b of the budget the answer yeah
yes section 39 of the budget with repeal
rsa to 30 games
which is precisely what this bill is
about right
that was also the governor's questions
thank you for taking my really genuine
question
if we pass it does that mean if we pass
it here
right give our recommendation does that
give
leadership the choice of letting it be a
stand-alone bill
which at this point would feel really
good to know it's standalone because i
don't see how anybody
could be against it and the fact that it
somehow got in the budget would be
irrelevant
if we pass it the language in the budget
doesn't include these new provisions
can we supersede it if we
if we pass the bill separately
i mean we have to recommend it
and then it can get voted on it can get
voted on
if it passes by itself
would that automatically affect the
budget
no because it's different
to a difference that it's moved from rsa
rsa318b
to rsa 126 a so whatever amendments we
make that rsa 318b
go away when that section of law is
appealed and it reverts to the section
that ben's put in place in a
126k representative whoever is perfectly
correct we could
pass the bill in table but then if
further changes have to be made from
fall one of us would have to file
another bill to make those changes
whereas if we retain it we have a
vehicle then
we can then immediately make whatever
changes are needed if no changes are
needed then we can say it's unnecessary
so it's really a procedure
representative
that that was the clarification that i
was looking for
um i you know and i i want to clarify in
turn
if if we as a house and senate pass two
um conflicting bills the the deciding
factor is which one
is signed most recently by the governor
so but what i had not
really fully grasped was representative
marsha's point
about having a vehicle available
not so much the conflicts with the
budget but having a vehicle
available should a quick fix be needed
because this
would carry with it the possibility
if not the reality that we could get it
done quicker than
if it required a whole new bill so
his his point is well taken in that
respect
yes representative folsom thank you mr
chair
um
if we uh retain it
is it possible for us as a committee
to not take an official vote but more of
a stronghold
so that we can
highly recommend i highly recommend yes
but not officially recommend
so that leadership knows what our intent
is with what's in retaining or is that
just something
that can be verbally shared
with them i would think it would be
better verbally shared i'm not sure
representative weber can help me but i'm
not sure that we
actually have a device to do that
well if i may mr chairman
there there's nothing to stop the chair
asking for a straw poll on anything it
doesn't actually
have any effect on anything
and certainly anybody from the committee
is uh welcome to convey their
their you know thoughts and and
and on any of our proceedings to anybody
so there's no problem with conveying it
verbally
and there is no problem certainly with
taking a straw poll if the chair
desires to do so but it doesn't have any
effect other than we know what we did
and and the clerk will have a and the
clerk will certainly have a record of it
so that
in that respect it might be useful
anybody like that idea of a straw poll i
like stroke balls
struggles fine
then let us take a straw poll which is
not an official vote
but i'd like to know how many people um
are affirming this in the straw poll and
the straw poll
is that we like this bill as it was
presented to us
and in some manner or other depending on
what happens to
rsa 318 and so on we would like this to
go forward so
i guess the straw fall is we like the
build
informally without writing it down but
using your names
i would like to have that
role called so i can when i write a
letter um
say that so many people affirmed this
in an unofficial struggle and so many
people didn't
so would the clerk call the role on the
straw poll that we
affirm 45.
thank you thank you it's not a vote i
mean it is a vote but it's not an
official vote it came in late
so far i haven't heard it assumed that
it was
45 yes it is
um representative nelson yes
representative acton yes representative
yes representative christian yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
kobalt
yes representative weber
yes representative mckay yes
representative snow yes representative
conner
yes representative soloway yes
representative cannon yes representative
france
letter thank you yes but i
i i'd like a little more clarification
on the best way
to actually get it passed you know let's
finish the
roll call and then we'll go back to that
okay thanks
representative shapiro yes
representative yes representative
merchant
no and representative pearson
yes
mr chairman one second i think that's 19
to 1.
yes representative marshall
yes with the understanding that you will
write a letter
to the senate uh finance committee
saying that we
overwhelmingly support this language we
added
the rsa 126 a language if not still two
i will move that we retain uh senate
bill 45
so that if somehow that does not happen
we then can deal with this
i write a letter to the senate uh
finance
that we want this bill's language
um brsa126a
language 126 a
89.
salloway would like to second that
motion
you missed your chance representative
sullivan represent
[Music]
okay i'm one step previous and that's
what i have to do next i have that then
i heard
if the chairman is willing and the
chairman is willing
representative marsh moved to retain and
representative soloway
seconded any further discussion
representative
representative weber
i i have two i have one point and one
question
um i am while i
understand representative
marsh's thoughts on
having a vehicle available
it seems to me that this
committee is surrendering a great deal
of its authority if we do
not choose to either pass or itl
this bill because
we are then at the mercy of what happens
in the budget
and we there have been times when
budgets have not
passed at all and if that is true then
nothing's going to happen here either
uh so that's the concern i have with the
proposed process i
i really think that this term
the policy committees have surrendered a
great deal of their authority to the
budget process
and i do not think that that is good
policy
either now or in the future uh i
understand that covid makes things much
more difficult but i think it's a bad
precedent to start
the other thing is that we have not
heard
uh my second my second point is that we
have not heard from representative
merchants
about his opposition to this bill but
given that he is
intimately involved in working with the
pdmp in one way or another
i would very much want to hear his
thoughts and
others we took a straw poll without
hearing that
and my opinion might change based on
what i hear from other members of the
committee so
i want people to bear that firmly in
mind because
my my vote may change we have not yet
had a discussion
and again that is a further erosion of
the the committee process of discussion
before votes so i'm going to bump
representative merchant to the top of my
list of those wishing to speak so he can
speak to that very point i was
going down the same line of thinking um
madame ranking member thank you
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman um i think the
bill
the intent of it is something i can
support the way that bill's written i
could not
and my rationale to that is if you go
back into line
three and four where it says dispenser
with
medication reconciliation that is not
always done by the dispenser sometimes
it's done by the prescriber
so therefore i think the prescriber
should have the same language in there
as well as the dispenser because
there's times in which a physician will
do med reconciliation not just the
pharmacist
and in that capacity the position is not
a dispenser they're actually a
prescriber
number two when you get down to line 14
a practitioner who neither prescribes or
dispenses
who's not actively working as a
pharmacist with the new hampshire
licensed pharmacy
or a new hampshire healthcare facility
that does not
talk about a practitioner being a
physician
um because in that point in time looking
at somebody
who works in it but the thing is if you
don't work inside of the facility
if you're a physician and prescribing
from your home you're exempt from this
because it doesn't include the fact that
you're licensed by the state
it talks about where you're performing
the activity not the fact that you have
access to the database
when you're retired so if you're retired
as a pharmacist or a physician
you can still have access to the
database which we're trying to minimize
and to eliminate and if you put the fact
that they have to be in a
physical facility not by the licensure
that becomes a problematic
number three when you look at number 23
lying about the query and retrieval of
the database
it's not patient specific so my concern
is that the way it's written
a program can be written in such a way
that's querying the whole database
and pulling back and retrieval not
something is patient specific
but pulling back a lot of the database
that's not really connected to a
particular patient
number four i think the patient should
be aware of the fact that you're taking
data from one database
and putting into another database
because they have access to the database
that they want
to in the prescription drug monitoring
program to see whose footprints are all
over
their data when it goes an electronic
medical record inside of a hospital
they they don't have access that way you
have to go through another process to
get access to it
so for those reasons i don't support the
bill the way it's written i could
support the bill if it's modified
thank you representative cushman
i put my hand down uh representative
weber asked my question thank you
representative acton uh
yes thank you mr chair and thank you for
the time
i i have to concur with um
representative weber about this i'm very
worried that
by retaining it's it's going to get
thrown into a budget process that we
have no
control over at this point and it's not
looking good as far as the
the budget fight that and so a lot of
this may wind up on the negotiating room
floor
the other thing is that the the need has
been demonstrated by
practitioners this is a source of
trouble for them
uh that need is now so retaining is just
another way to kind of put it off uh we
need more of a sense of urgency i
believe and whatever it takes to get
this done
this this this session now is is what
i'll support
thank you
gay thank you after listening to all of
y'all
come up with ideas about how to tighten
the bill
i would really prefer that that those
be submitted in an amendment
because you know right now we're not
looking at
59 bills to look at it seems like it
would be worth
doing it correctly and making it into a
separate bill
not the budgets can come and go
line items can come and go i also like
lucy
pardon me representative would like to
see this as a standalone
bill as it was submitted and support
that
whatever they want to do with the budget
they can do but
that's fluid i'd like this to stand
so but with the corrections in it
because we certainly don't want to
break the intent by leaving out some
critical words
the chair calls on himself and um
i'm one i've been wondering and i think
representative merchant's
concerns bumped me a little forward
if language were put in through an
amendment
that underlined five
and wherever the number 318 appears
again
if we set a licensed hospital pharmacy
under
rsa 318 or
should 318 be abolished
126 a 89 that way
the bill comes out meaning wherever you
folks put this stuff
this is where we want this to go
i mean that may be too simple to be
good but that's what i thought and then
at that point
we could on the quick um representative
merchant and
others who may be sharing your concern
uh
offer that as part of the amendment or
there could be two committee amendments
and we will come back at some point
fairly soon
and uh address this uh how does that
sound to the crowd
mr chairman i i was put my hand up to
to very much second the comments of
representative gay but i will second
yours as well
uh we've got plenty of time and we have
two bills so far so there is
enough time for representative merchant
to draft
um an amendment with his concerns
in it so that we can all take a good
look at it and the other thing just for
for members of the committee to know is
that you're absolutely correct
the um
drafting staff in ols has a great
deal of expertise in drafting
alternatives in their legislation and i
have sometimes seen them get
quite involved and this one doesn't need
to be that involved
but in the event that this other bill
passes this happens and in the event
that this
other bill fails that happens so i
i think there is room for that to happen
as as part of a reconciliation
process but also right there in the bill
and
i certainly would be much happier uh
waiting to see what representative
merchant and
others who might want to speak to him
come up with
because i think the points that he makes
are very valid and i would like to see
them
examined and incorporated if if that's
the will of the committee
chair uh representative webber let me
come back to you on that and do you
think it would be wise for the
uh my concern about language saying 318
or wherever phpv
lands be in his amendment as well or
would that be
another amendment that i would craft i
think that would be a subject
for the people drafting to discuss with
ols
because they have more experience in
doing that than i and i generally leave
those men
to hand to them thank you representative
marsh
mr chair i would like
[Music]
representative soloway will you withdraw
your second
yes uh mr chairman i will withdraw the
second thank you
and thank you to um representative
marsh on that i will check with
um ols
about whether that could be or should be
one or two amendments
and look back in with representatives
marching merchant and marsh and
uh give a few more minutes if anybody
else would like to
uh right now throw in some thoughts
knowing that you can
talk with representatives merchant and
marsha about the big amendment
so anybody now still before we move on
to the next bill
want to weigh in
[Music]
sounds like a good plan
representative matter of fam i had said
i'd get back to you and i didn't but
here i am so
you wanted to say something a little
while ago
no i this is i think this is a good plan
and so my questions have been answered
and then when we get a look at the
amendment
it'll be clearer how we're going to vote
you know
retain or pass now or all that so thank
you
thank you anyone else last minute
okay then mr can i just say it quick
oh you you beat me by about
four and a half inches go okay good uh i
i just want to quickly go back to um and
thank you by the way mr chair uh
i i just want to go quickly back to what
what senator guy mentioned about
um at some point we need to put reliance
upon the the belief that the the
practitioners are going to do the right
thing i think
too many times when when we're in
government we may be jaded because we
happen to see a lot of
problems and so forth that we we tend to
start
persevering too much on the wrong doers
and we forget that the vast vast
majority of
people who do the right thing or want to
wind up getting it inconvenienced
because we're building in so many
regulations and rules to go after
that tiny percentage that may want to
take advantage of this so i just wanted
to call attention to that and
and just remind people of that thank you
thank you okay with that
the um
totally blanked the term um exec session
on senate bill 45 has come to a close
and now i open the hearing on senate
bill
one two zero relative to
physician assistant medical services
through the manchester veterans
administration
medical center and we have senator
sherman as the prime sponsor
and senator sherman you may proceed
thank you mr chair can you hear me yes
awesome um well uh
thank you uh mr chairman and hello to
my friends in the committee on health
and human services i always feel like
i'm coming home when i'm
in front of that's because you've been
here before yes i have
um so for the record my name is senator
tom sherman district 24 representing
11 towns on the seacoast
and i am introducing sb 120.
this is a bill that was requested by
physician assistants
and i believe uh linda martino is here
to testify and she can speak
in more detail to this i did want to
um basically outline
the rationale behind this and that's
that in
the statute which is 328 d2a
there was not the clear provision
that new hampshire physician assistants
in other words physician assistants
licensed in new hampshire
can work under physicians
from elsewhere who are at and employed
by the va
in manchester or the va the veterans
administration
medical center so that was the point of
the bill
was to make it possible for physician
assistants
to practice at the
va under you know pas have to work
uh uh under the supervision of a
physician
but as we all know many of the or
that the truth is that there are many uh
physicians
at the va who are not credentialed
in new hampshire so that was the point
of this
was to allow new hampshire physician
assistants to work
under those physicians there has been
some confusion
because the original bill the statute
if you look at line eight
it says new hampshire well line 78 says
new hampshire
state licensure laws rules and
regulations for physician assistance
are hereby suspended for those physician
assistants from other states or
countries who are employed
and then it keeps going uh in the that's
pretty that's current existing statute
in the bill as introduced
uh i had inadvertently struck out
war countries uh and
um when it was coming to the floor of
the senate after having been approved
with you know by the committee with
unanimous support
the pas and va uh
recognized that that should not have
been stricken
because it actually is pre-existing
statute and i've gotten a couple of
emails from members of the commission
committee from your committee on this i
just wanted to tell you
where this came from so the floor
amendment reinstated the original
statutory language
i don't have a strong opinion on whether
or not
that was that's appropriate but what we
did was
just re reestablish the current statute
so with that i am happy to answer any
questions i
can on the bill and
and i believe linda is here and she can
speak
specifically to the pa role at
the va i guess that makes them
vapas but anyway um it's okay with me
yeah i have a question
um i know there are similarities and
differences between pas and nurse
practitioners
i employ two nurse practitioners no
physicians assistants
but my eye doctor employs two pas and no
nurse practitioners so right in our
conversation we
compare and contrast uh would
you be amenable
to adding nurse practitioners
to physician assistants
well thank you for the question
technically in new hampshire that would
not be necessary because nurse
practitioners
are allowed to practice independently
okay pas are not
so uh it's not an
intentional well it is an intentional
exclusion because they don't need this
nurse practitioners in new hampshire
have the right to practice independently
and do not have to be under the
supervision
of a physician which is one of the you
know they have different training
and i would be clobbered by my favorite
nurse practitioners if i said they're
very similar
so i won't say that and
also by my favorite pas they are they
have different
scopes of practice they have different
roles
as patients we see them you know
doing sort of the same things in many
cases but
actually unless you have a physician
in your practice mr chair you would not
be able to have a pa
practicing because they have to be they
have to have an identified
physician supervisor so i have a pa who
works
under me as and i'm her identified
supervisor
but my nurse practitioner does not need
any of that she is
independent can practice on her own uh
and she's overseen by the board of
nursing
thank you for reminding me of that my
second question to you
is i see an amendment uh
put by representatives canaric and marsh
represent
amendment 1107 h
it seems to me that the difference is
in line 15 of the
bill the word or countries is struck
it's not in the amendment and in line 20
the same thing however if you go up into
line eight
in the amendment or country still
appears
so um either that
is for a reason that i can't figure out
or they got two-thirds of the references
to um countries oh
so the the difference between those
lines
eight and lines 16
and 22 is that 16 and 22 are referring
to the supervising physicians
okay and line eight uh is referring to
the actual physician assistants
um i i would just caution the committee
uh and i i don't have a strong feeling
on this
but i would defer to the va on
whether this is going to impede um
what they're trying to do because you
know
it as we all know workforce and health
care is a
huge is in some level of crisis
and um so i don't know if they have
uh physicians from other countries who
are
working i know they do have physicians
from other countries
working in their um
uh working in their practices
the i think the the difference here is
whether they have a
you know a u.s license so i have many
colleagues
in the medical field who are really
quite outstanding physicians who
attended medical school did their
residency
and other training abroad came to the
united states they
are among the top in their field either
at harvard or
duke or barnes or any of the
wonderful hospitals but they are
licensed to practice in the united
states so
the only question i would i would defer
to the va
on this um i think
we don't want to be limiting physicians
um by their country or state of origin
as much as we would want to be sure they
have a
us license
and that that's what's highly regulated
in terms of their
competency so and also
by the way not just competency but their
ongoing monitoring
because we are one of the most highly
monitored uh occupations i think
that there is probably next to airline
pilots um
so i would on that question on that
amendment
i would just caution
to make sure if there's going to be a
change
that we're not blocking supervision by
out-of-country physicians but we want
those physicians that
are supervising to be licensed
in the united states not that they have
to be from the united states
um so anyway that that's my only comment
and i would defer to the va
uh the people from the va as to uh
the exact wording here and whether as as
far as i know right now they have
no out of country physicians
on their staff but it would be better to
ask them that
thank you very much any other questions
for senator sherman
representative merchant ah thank you mr
chair and thank you senator for taking
my question
um i concur with the issue of having
licensure
within the u.s versus the country in
which they reside
and following that theme would it be
logical then for a physician assistant
to also be licensed by new hampshire
or state within the united states if you
will
back to the same concern is that we have
a standard of care
which is what licensing board creates
and therefore if the physician assistant
wanted to be
practicing in hampshire in you will
within the united states that they would
be
required to have a license by
a state agency in one of the states
regardless of the country they come from
it's
not so much a question of where the
residence is what country they're from
but do they actually in fact hold a
legitimate license to practice here
in new hampshire the united states
uh thank you for the question as i
as i mentioned in my little introduction
that is
currently in statute so um
i was i was asked to reinstate it
with my floor amendment um so
i agree with you though that the key
again not only to setting level of
competency which is licensure
whether it's nursing or physicians or
pas but
also being able to monitor you know one
of the things
we learned in exeter back with the
hepatitis c
outbreak is that if you don't monitor
somebody
you you can't keep track of bad behavior
and
that's why we established the only
board of registry of medical technicians
in the country
because the guy who was at exeter had
been to 16 other facilities before he
came and
did did his dastardly deed on
on our hospital so um
so i think licensure in the u.s for
anybody practicing in the u.s
unless there's a compelling argument
against that is something that i would
be in favor of
because it really allows us that ongoing
monitoring as well as
setting a basic level of competency
representative gay thank you and thank
you for taking my question
um as a as a non-profit as a non-medical
professional person
i'm just looking at the wording and in
the original bill
line 15 it talks about
you know when it says a person's from
another country to me that doesn't say
anything about their licensure
or their presence so when it says
provided they possess
a current license in good standing in
their respective state or country
i thought a doctor to practice here had
to be licensed
here that's question a
question may be answered first okay
that's the same word
on that question so it's my
understanding
that within the veterans administration
system
because they have so much flux that they
are typically
you have to have a license to practice
as is mentioned here but
it does not necess because it's a
federal program
you do not necessarily have to have a
license i would have to check this but
you do not have to have a license in the
state in which
your va is where where your va is it's
sort of like
more of a national program you do have
to be licensed
to practice medicine
but it's my understanding that it
doesn't necessarily have to be the state
of new hampshire if you look at that
existing statute
new hampshire state licensure laws rules
and regulations
are suspended now that's physician
assistance i'd have to go back and look
at the statute
for providers whether it's nurse
practitioners or physicians
but you do have to still be licensed
so i hope i don't know if that really
answers your question i don't have a
full answer
on how they handle um
physicians in the va system but they do
have to be licensed
hello
i'm wondering if there are va hospitals
all around the world
in which case you would have employ
you could be employing doctors from or
medical care people
from that country which could be spelled
out here because
i'm surprised surprised the bill doesn't
say exactly everything
but i would think that they would have
to be
licensed where they are practicing
is that certainly if they're from
another country that doesn't
you know that seems immaterial are they
licensed to practice
where they are and that would
if it said that it would cover
uh medical facilities around the world
i'm just concerned about where they're
licensed
because it appears multiple places in
the bill
right remember this thank you for the
question this bill is
only about physician assistance this is
not
dealing with licensure for physicians or
nurse practitioners
so it's it's trying to address the issue
of new hampshire
pas who want to practice at the va
and because of the set the structure of
the va
they have physicians from other states
and apparently other countries although
i've been told they don't have any
currently
and so a pa cannot practice in the state
of new hampshire
without having a physician supervisor
so that's the the entire intent of the
bill we are not trying to go
into the va rules and regulations
and the new hampshire statutes that work
with the va
when it comes to providers like nurse
practitioners or physicians
you raise a good question about what are
those rules and regs
but some of it is federal because the va
is a federal system
and some of it is how new hampshire has
adapted
to allow the va to continue in
manchester
and one of the things that i would also
say
is that our goal here is to make it
easier for our veterans to access
the care they need that's the goal and
the way this bill makes that
easier is by allowing our pas to
practice
at the manchester va and their
facilities
that's all this is intended to do it's
not trying to change
existing statute it's just trying to
make sure that new hampshire pas
can practice under the supervision
of a a va
doctor
thank you senator sherman is there
anyone else who has not asked a couple
of questions who would like to ask a
question
representative weber
representative weber thank you
uh just just so we're clear
we have before us a bill with some
changes on
line um
1516 that we've been discussing and some
and 20 and 21 that we've been discussing
and we also have an amendment
that had that changes some of that
language
and it am i correct in understanding
that the bill
as it brought was brought to us
would allow the supervising physician
to be licensed either in any state in
the united states
or in another country and that is as the
language
of the statute is now anyway and
the amendment would restrict
licensing only to those
restrict supervision only to those
physicians
who have a license somewhere in the
united states is that
a fair assessment of where we are right
now
uh i do not have a copy of the amendment
so i
apologize my concern from whoever was
reading the amendment
earlier was that it didn't do that my
concern was that what it did was it said
that
uh physicians from other countries
follow up mr chairman could not and
that's that would be a problem if it's
if it's limiting licensure to u.s they
have to have a u.s
license remember what you're doing in
this
is um and and it's
it's fine because you're restricting it
to pas but i would be
cautious about limiting what physicians
can practice
or which physicians can practice at the
va
all you're doing here if you have this
amendment as
i'm hoping it's written i see
representative knurk
looking like it it probably does just
limit it to licensure in the united
states
if that's what it does it's saying that
if you have a pa
from new hampshire that wants to
practice at the va
that pa can be monitored can be
supervised by a physician either from
the united states or another country but
they have to have a u.s license
might i just read you the language um
i i'm up to that i'd like to do
something that i did once before and
that is actually call upon the person
who is the prime of the amendment
uh and representative webber i'll circle
back around but representative kenner
could you uh please clarify
uh your intent in the amendment and dr
blitz has this
yes yes because i i did want to speak
but since i was
testifying i couldn't speak or ask a
question so
first important understand that the
amendment does not affect
people who just happen to come from
another country
indeed we have an enormous number of
foreign foreign-born graduates who work
in this country it has to do with just
licensure and what it says in the
current statute 328
d2a it says new hampshire state
licensure laws regulations
for physicians assistance are hereby
suspended for those
physician assistants from other states
or countries
it never says physicians
so that so when they ask it to be put in
the other language
from the statute and the word physicians
from other countries
that does not exist in the statute the
issue was that it had to cover
out of country physician assistants
because there are some of those
who are in existence i don't know if
they're currently employed
so the point is this amendment
does not bring back the current
statutory language
and what it does it for example let's
say you are from england
and you are going to be working on the
va system and
but you're going to be licensed in this
country where your license is going to
come from a state
and you will not get for example a
license in the state of massachusetts
unless you were
residing there when you applied for it
so that's why when you say from another
state that person from massachusetts can
come up and work at the
va with no problem because they are
licensed in the state of massachusetts
the fact they're born in another country
has nothing to do with uh
with what we're talking about we're not
talking about birthplace the licensure
um that basically what happened is when
i read this it caught my eye
bill marsh and i were both sponsors uh
co-sponsors and the language wasn't in
what we signed off on
and that's when i found out it was
supposedly it was to add this language
from the statute in but i put
the original bill and the statute and
all this up and
another computer i kept going back and
forth and it just simply doesn't exist
about out-of-country
physicians it's out-of-country physician
assistance
so anyway the point is if you look at
the wording on
the amendment it it simply takes out
in line 15 physicians from other
countries uh well actually you look at
the whole sentence
physicians from other states are
countries provided that possess a
current license a good standing in their
respective state or
country because the way it was written a
person licensed just to practice
only in uh let us say south africa
but not licensed at all in the united
states would be able to supervise one of
the pas that's what the
that's what a strict reading would say
as it is now
that person could be born in south
africa trained in south africa
moved to united states licensed in the
state of virginia
is now transferred up to work at the va
in new hampshire
perfectly able to do that because
they're licensed in a u.s
state so that's all it does is i think
it clarifies that and i don't think it
may i personally don't think it makes
confusing
but if indeed our grammatical coaches
uh representative weber feel that it
still is not clear then we might want to
redraft it
to make certain that it says that it
doesn't preclude a person born
out of the country but again because you
can't get a state a licensure in this
country without having
at least resided here for a while i
think that's not a problem
and so the second part there in line 20
again just gets out of the word
out of country physicians uh because
again it's referring to
so they actually licensure this it's not
referring to where they're born
and yeah i'll take questions obviously
well not yet
you were not going you just no problem i
just want to say that
the goal is to make it work i'm not
worried i'm not wedded to this language
if it's not right fix it
all right could i just comment on the
amendment then
yes senator sherman so
i would ask representative knurk to
make sure that he has looked at existing
statute
for va physicians practice which i
uh just to make sure that this does not
run afoul of what we allow the va to
have
i i in other words i would check with
the va
and check with statute to make sure this
doesn't have
unintended consequences for
uh anybody but i agree with the i don't
have a problem with the
the intent of this which i and i do
agree that uh
i think it's important that our pas are
supervised by people who have licenses
in the united states may i answer to
that
checking i checked with linda martino
who is going to be seeking and richard
laflamme
they are the pas and the people from the
va who are involved in this
because they did multiple emails back
and forth and they were in agreement
that this part regarding out-of-country
physicians
could be struck but let's hear it
straight from them before not processed
through me they'll be coming up
i know that they're listed on the
testifying list as well thank you all
right i'm going to circle back his
promise to representative webber
thank you mr chairman and i just wanted
to
say that i think the the reason i wanted
to read the language
to senator sherman
is that i think that the language says
much more clearly and in many fewer
words
exactly what representative clerk just
explained to us
and i also wanted to let senator sherman
know that i have taken a photograph
of the amendment and i got it thank you
and i've also asked uh committee
services to
email you a copy so you shall soon be in
undated with copies of
amendment 1107h but
the language as drafted in the amendment
says may be supervised by physicians
and here is the problem that might come
up because it says
from other states and we don't care
where they're
from we care where they're licensed the
second half says
provided they possess a current license
and good standing in their represent
in their respective state so we may need
to remove the words
from other states because
as has been said a number of times we
don't care where they're
from they could be from anywhere
provided they have a license in good
standing
in one of the other united states
as opposed to anywhere else so i think
there may be room for
a little more work but i think we're
getting
yeah the only uh the only other comment
i'd make uh
on that is and i'd have to think this
through
is whether that actually has to read may
be supervised by physicians from new
hampshire
or other states because we don't want it
to
exclude although the may may allow it to
exist for new hampshire but
you don't want to say well they can't be
supervised by a physician from new
hampshire
because it says only from other states
so i'm just follow up mr chairman
yes please if instead of saying
by super uh
by physicians from other states which
then
might arguably preclude physicians from
other countries
if we said by physicians
not licensed in new hampshire because
it's the license that we care about not
where they're from
[Music]
may be supervised by physicians not
licensed in new hampshire
provided they possess a current license
in good standing
from one of the united states
or however i think that that sounds good
and it could be just
it could stay in their respective state
um right but however you wanted to do
well
i think weird that they've got to have a
a license from somewhere in the united
states that's right
thank you another question about this
um excuse me representative woods is up
next
uh thank you mr chair um and uh thank
you
senator sherman uh good to see you um
uh had actually several questions some
of which have been answered
um i i just going through from uh
my first question was in the first line
uh line five
on the amended senate bill uh new
hampshire state licensure laws rules and
regulations for physician assistance
the way i read it and i'm not an
attorney uh that would seem that that
would suspend
any licensure laws
suspend any rules would suspend any
regulations
my sense that it would should read
because we're only dealing with
licensure
that the new hampshire state laws
regarding new hampshire state laws rules
and regulations regarding licensure
because otherwise it seems like it would
read that they would be
not subject to the board of medicines
other besides licensing that wouldn't be
subjected to
the rules and regulations as promulgated
by the board of medicine
which and again i may be uh i'm not an
attorney
and it may read perfectly fine uh right
now
um i have uh secondly i have concerns
um about this issue of licensure
and supervising from a distance
the whole concept at least as i
understand it
was that there was some kind of
cooperative
and collaborative i think as a correct
rsa term
um activity in other words uh
when i was in practice we had pas in the
office and if there was a difficulty and
just like um sir
senator our representative marsh if
there's a
question comes up they're right there we
can
collaborate and formulate a plan
i have concerns about being at a
distance
and what that means if it's uh
something uh that occurs at three in the
morning am i going to call somebody in
arizona
um i don't know that that really works
very well
uh so i have i have i understand and i i
understand the need
and i understand the intent and i'm i
really would like to work
such that we can do that um i'm not too
sure the way it's
formulated and the way it's worded right
now that it accomplishes that
i do have concerns that this is also a
um
a situation that could be a precedent
that's uh
let's pretend and read the read the rsa
instead of the va as uh convenient md
how would that would we do that for
convenient md
now if i if i could just uh
jump to your second question first
the intent here is not to have
telesupervision
these are physicians practicing at the
manchester va
is my understanding who are overseeing
so they are actually practicing at the
va
they don't practice outside the va and
they do not have a new hampshire license
they have a license in another state
because the va system
as i mentioned earlier is a federal
system
so this would not be somebody
supervising a pa from arizona this would
be somebody
who has an arizona license practicing at
the va in manchester
and directly supervising the pa
okay so that may be my mit that may i'm
not reading it correctly then
the way i read it is that they could be
no no no it's not
it has nothing to do with site or site
of origin or any telemedicine or
telesupervision i think that would be
setting a huge precedent for pas
uh and that would stated well
um i i leave that up to the committee
uh i don't think it needs to be stated
because it would certainly
never i don't see that as being allowed
uh but um you know we'd have to go into
va rules and regs and all that kind of
stuff but my understanding is that
this is direct supervision which is the
standard of practice for
pas certainly in new hampshire um
and then and and if the committee
feels that that needs to be specified
i'm absolutely fine with that
because i agree with you representative
wood
woods that this is we're not we're not
embarking on
tele supervision uh the second one
is seven through nine um
is existing statute it's beyond the
scope of
the intent of the bill and the actual
bill to try to rewrite
existing statute this was to make it
possible
the single goal of this bill was to make
it possible
for pas from new hampshire to be
working at the va under the supervision
of a
non-new hampshire physician that's the
goal
and so if the i
i think you could have mission creep if
you try to get into that because we
you would have to be absolutely sure
that you are not impacting
current standards of practice at the va
um
but uh i hear your concern uh but it is
not within the goal of this bill
to impact that first part of that of
chapter
thank you thank you representative woods
next up on my list is representative
shapiro
thank you mr chairman and i apologize
for
interrupting before um i understand that
the
um term and out of state
is already in statute or there's some
question about whether it is or not but
i'm wondering if
um out of state
would preclude people who were not in
another state but were licensed in the
united states
um like puerto rico or washington dc
that's a really good question yes so
maybe
state or territory uh
would be more inclusive and i see
representative kanerk is got his red pen
out
so yeah follow up um
in other states um
however um on line 19 it says
out of state so out of state could
include those territories but
in another state would not include those
territories
[Music]
i love this committee you guys find
stuff
you just make bills better so thank you
representative nelson
my question was just answered about
using the word states
we're all set thank you anyone else who
hasn't
asked a question representative snow
unmuted representative snowden
since last week on a bill that this
committee
passed last year the senate signed it
and the governor
signed it and it i know
i'm moneying the waters by bringing in a
bill that's not part of this public
hearing
but i need welcome senator snow i want
to hear that and i think it's going to
be
important but can we push you back in
the line absolutely
all right so i'm writing uh your name
here it's not a prayer request for
precipitation it is a reminder to me
to make sure you get to do that anyone
else who has not
asked a question of the senator
okay representative gay one more okay
thank you um thank you for clarifying
the whole
goal of this since we've talked about
many details
i want to make sure i will state what i
think the goal of this
is of this bill and amendment and
please correct it if it's not right to
me
the goal is to allow hiring
pas from other states or countries
so that they can work under
at the of anywhere in the va coordinated
through the veterans
the amc work under the direct
supervision
of a doctor who is
certified to work for the va i'm trying
to circumvent
state law versus federal law on
recognizing the physician
but the whole goal is to allow us to
hire
more pas who are not licensed
in this state but they are
licensed well i don't even not even
quite sure
where they're licensed but they would
work under
a licensed physician
who is appropriately credentialed
to work in the va um
thank you for the question um the answer
is uh
the it is already allowed for
a pa in lines seven through nine
in existing statute for pas
from other states or countries to work
in new hampshire
what is not currently allowed based on
new hampshire statute
is for new hampshire licensed pas
to work under the supervision of
physicians
who do not have a new hampshire license
and the only place in the state that i
know of where
this would apply is at the va
so new hampshire pas
who want to practice at the va currently
half can only practice under a provider
under a physician who has a new
hampshire license
and what this bill does is
and and that there's a possibility that
no one working at the va would fit that
description
um because the va is a federal system
and their physicians are licensed as
we've been discussing
but but they may not be licensed in the
state in which they're practicing
so because it's a federal system so what
that means
is that in this setting the pas
covered under the bill are new hampshire
licensed pas they have to identify a
supervising physician
and this bill makes it possible for them
to work
at the va taking care of our new
hampshire veterans
under the supervision of a
va physician
who may not have a new hampshire license
that's all the bill does
so it doesn't address pas from out of
state that's
already in statute
thank you senator and thank you for your
testimony in asking the
answering these questions the chair now
recognizes linda
martino or should i say linda martino pa
linda martino is just fine yes i am a pa
good morning chairman pearson and
committee members i thank you very much
for your allowing me to speak
today um as as i mentioned i'm linda
martino i'm also a member of the
board of the new hampshire society pas
and i'm also a council member of the new
hampshire medical society
both organizations and i are in support
of
sb 120.
which senator sherman succinctly put
that
really just increases the access of care
for veterans by
allowing more pas to help um i would
like to acknowledge
and my comment to that is brief because
i have a colleague that will be speaking
after me
his name is richard laflamme he's an
active service member and
and he can answer your questions based
on his experience
and i just want to acknowledge today
that we have pa students that are
intended
at this hearing watching our legislators
in action today
so thank you all for your time and i
defer questions to my colleague
richard laflamme and thank you ms
martino and now the chair calls
richard laflamme pa
sorry about that can you hear my voice
at this point
yes all right thank you um again my name
is richard the flam
i'm a physician assistant i'm employed
by the
veterans administration i'm a military
pa
part of the new hampshire army national
guard where i carry the rank of major
i i'm here representing myself in
neither of those
agencies officially and i want to thank
uh the legislators and our sponsors for
hearing
this important issue and i've heard a
lot of very vigorous discussion and i
appreciate the thoughtfulness
of our legislators as they poured over
every word to make sure that this is
right
um and i am one of the people for which
this board will have
or the the impact of this legislation
will have direct effect
uh in my life in that i work for the
home-based primary care program i go and
see veterans in their home
my medical director dr joseph leinert
has uh also
uh offered his support for this
legislation and this morning i
forwarded an email to um dr
kirk and uh sherman uh voicing that
concern he currently represents 25
of all of the pas that work at the
manchester va
and he is licensed in maine so while he
is our medical director as it has been
pointed out
he cannot serve as my direct uh
supervising physician
and for both an administrative function
as well as just the clarity of having
that direct collaborative agreement with
the physician
who's in the best position to help me
manage our veterans at home
i really do appreciate the leadership um
to
identify this gap and to potentially
close it
using these documents i agree that the
scope and scale of it
is limited to what we were intending to
allow
my boss for example to supervise me
directly
to meet the board of medicine
requirements i value the collaboration
and i think instead of having to find
other physicians from outside of other
departments
who happen to be licensed in new
hampshire we find ourselves
meeting the law but more the spirit of
it
rather than that actual collaborative
agreement would more accurately reflect
my practice so thank you so much for
creating this this forum and allowing me
to participate
i would be happy to answer any specific
question about my practice
in the va um to assuage any other fears
that may not have been addressed so far
any questions from angela flom
[Music]
representative merchants thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um mister blom
as far as working in the va system it's
my understanding hopefully you can
clarify this for me
that in order to work in the va system
you have to have a license
issued by a state or territory within
the united states of the confines of the
u.s so therefore if i'm licensed in new
hampshire i could practice in the va
system in california hawaii wherever
else i wanted to
i think it's the same with a physician
assistant
so that's the question before you is
when you're in the va system
do you in fact have to have a license
issued by a state or territory in the us
that's absolutely true in some cases
what people will do is they'll find the
the most expeditious license if you will
the easiest one to maintain
or one that was more in keeping with
what they're hoping for with minimal
administrative burdens
and as a result our we may have more
physician assistants that are here in
working
but just have not elected to use the new
hampshire licensure
because of some of these cumbersome
requirements for supervising
uh agreements you are 100 correct that
and the federal government is uh both in
the military and as well as in the va
very very uh strict in their
credentialing um
it's exhaustive uh every year we we we
go through it we dread it
there's a lot of checks and balances but
they only work within that federal
system and if they were to leave that or
to seek employment outside of the va as
perhaps moonlighting or whatever else
they would have to pursue that new
hampshire license
and and as it pointed out by colleagues
uh today
this is only to work within that federal
system
the one other little caveat would be
there are other federal organizations
like the prison system
that could potentially hire a pa but
that's not currently true
so i can say that this is a fairly
limited
scope and scale but again a new
hampshire pa
might go work in a different va
outside of new hampshire and would be
able to maintain
their work in that new va facility be it
in arizona
while using a new hampshire license
because of the rules of working at a
federal system
so you're right you have to have a
license in a state or territory in order
to function
there are not facilities outside of the
country that are not specifically
designed to meet the needs of
veterans it did just have some future
proof
language regarding perhaps pas that may
someday will be trained out of country
but they would still have to be licensed
in a state or territory in order to gain
employment
those rules are very you know are
updated periodically
but there has been absolutely no change
and as
has been pointed out it is not a
reflection of any
changes in scope scale of practice or
telemedicine it is
simply a measure of maintaining new
hampshire's
licensure and wanting to be in not only
in compliance with those regulations
but actually have supervisory agreements
that make the most sense
by having the right physician who knows
the pa
able to supervise them in that federal
setting
thank you for your question follow up mr
chair follow up
if i may so fundamentally look at this
law
what we're trying to do is allow for
treatment of the veterans
as if they were in the physical facility
of the veteran facility
but coordinated home care so they're not
being seen inside of a
federal facility they've been seen at
home or underneath the coordination of
the federal system but
the practice location of the practice
setting itself is outside of the federal
system so therefore
once we step outside of the federal
system we then come under the state
regulations
so this allows for the va to coordinate
activity that's within the state purview
that's under the federal system as far
as overseeing it is that kind of what
we're trying to get to
i think that's right i think the other
piece is that of course we have these
community-based outreach clinic the c
box so
it broadens some of that not all veteran
care is manchester va
but it all happens under the purview the
federal government didn't see bucks and
in some cases the homes
thank you thank you
the chair recognizes representative
acton
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
leflan for taking my question
i just want to briefly ask you more of a
general question for those of us who are
newer on the on the committee or um
aren't medically trained can you give us
some insight into the level of of
granularity of the supervisory
relationship that you have with your
physician is it done remotely do you
have to
pre-approve things what how much
autonomy do you have
in your medical practice that's a very
good question and i appreciate it
it is a topic um that's probably a
little bit
uh different for different pas and and
some of that is based upon your
degree of experience and what your
supervising physician has
outlined for you there are collaborative
agreements that are there that says
these are the things that i'm
comfortable with
these are things that i would like you
to reach out for in our particular case
well
my supervising physician um resides
in maine he has an office down at the
brady syllabus
in in manchester and he supervises
several uh pas and nurse practitioners
and he is always available and there's
always one of us that's covering for
this patient panel
in my particular case there are about 40
patients that are
around say tilton that he helps
collaborate with me
for their care we have weekly meetings
in a multi-disciplinary
setting where the social workers the
nurses and the physician all
collaborate on the care of our veterans
to make sure they're getting the
resources that they need
i may go independently into their home
to examine them
but he would of course always be aware
of what's happening
because all of my notes are sent to him
for both counter signature
and while i'm fully licensed within the
state to prescribe medication offer
diagnoses
in the sense of collaboration that when
on the day when i'm not working he needs
to be informed as to what's happening
and i also assist with his patients so
it is very much
a team sport as medicine is off practice
anywhere else the degree to which
my supervisor feels that he needs to or
she might need to
influence my care or to change what i've
done would be done on a case-by-case
basis based on the clinical progress of
a patient
it would be highly unusual that there
would be anything that's happening
by one of the pas that wasn't
immediately available or noticeable to
the supervising position
we have electronic charts they all sign
off on the same thing
and we have lots of team members that go
in as part of home-based primary care
we're sort of a medical strike team so
that collaboration is not just happening
from the pas
but the social workers and the
psychologists
or the pharmacists or the nursing staff
all of which
we meet together and review weekly the
care of our patients
i hope that that answers your questions
there's a degree of autonomy that comes
with
years of experience and confidence and a
strong relationship with your
supervising provider
and that could all change if your
patient's doing significantly better or
significantly worse
but it's really based on the actual care
that's needed
okay that's excellent information thank
you very much a pleasure
any other questions any
uh representative merchant is this an
old hand or a new hand
that's an old hand all right thank you
representative gay
thank you for uh thank you mr chairman
and thank you uh major leslam for taking
my question
yes ma'am okay um i'm concerned
you're you have been really filling us
in it's great information
uh i don't know if you have i guess you
don't have a copy of the amendment
excuse me but i'm now because you were
mentioning
uh something that sounded like cbox i'm
concerned to get the wording exactly
right
that says who who we are uh
who we are describing the current
wording
says um let's see
i'll get in the middle of sense because
it's a lot i think you're speaking of
line eight ma'am if i'm correct we were
talking about patient service
through uh manchester and now it says
coordinated through
the veterans administration medical
center yes
vamc at licensed medical facilities
which you are not working at
outside of the manchester vamc so
what is the exact way to copy this to
call
the service area that you're working in
so that it's accurate
yeah when we sat down and went over that
language
it was felt because again some of this
language was original to the rsa
and how it was defined in the original
exemptions
for the pas that worked at the
manchester va
it was felt that coordinated through the
vamc
represented the most accurate and
simplified language
because it allowed recognition that
there is both a robust care in the
community and that some of the care
of our veterans importantly as we do not
have a full service
medical treatment facility is often done
in the community
and it's done collaboratively we may ask
for consult that happens
in the community and then return to us
for ongoing care
but this was simplified language that
instead of it just
implying it only took place at the
manchester
campus but rather coordinated through
the veterans administration's medical
center
it is as an employee that is clear to me
but if it is not clear
to you then perhaps maybe that should be
readdressed
would it be accurate to say coordinated
through
but not at licensed medical facilities
outside the manchester vanc
i can see your point and i i would not i
would not uh
i would think that that would be fine to
remove that licensed medical
facilities and just use the language uh
or the facilities of the manchester
um or the department of veteran affairs
in the state of new hampshire
something that's a little bit more
inclusive that makes sense
thank you representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you uh
for out taking my question uh um
just out of curiosity if uh a situation
were to arise
about a particular uh pa
uh their standard of care or a problem
in their care
uh who would have the ultimate
responsibility in that regard uh
the va system or would they be subject
to the board of medicine
i think that's a great question and the
short answer is both sir
the board of medicine i've i've since
graduated
in 2007 have always been licensed in new
hampshire
both work at concord hospital and
throughout my other work and now through
the va
well i have a additional employer and i
have their standard of care
and a fortunately a very robust system
at the va where veterans and others can
make
raise concerns and have those concerns
addressed
through their professional development i
remain fully subject
to the new hampshire board of medicine
for any corrective action
any gaps in my care
or if a patient had a concern it would
be addressed
as it would be for any other pa that is
licensed
in new hampshire the only difference in
this particular case if this exception
was granted
but that my supervising physician who
happens to be licensed in maine
would also have to answer any concern
raised by the board of medicine
regarding his pa's scope or scale
practice
and i i feel like it should that i feel
like it should be that way
those agencies are designed to again
well they create many regulations
they're designed to to address
those rare individuals that do not
follow
standardized professional practice and
i'm glad that they're there to
to guide care and to protect the
patients
thank you thank you sir any other
questions for major lapham
seeing none thank you major appreciate
your testimony
an honor to be part of you mr and mr
chair then may i
uh speak for a moment well i was going
to get in
uh the other member who has signed up
from the state
i'm sorry my apologies ready and then
i'll give you last
bats the chair recognizes kevin grady
from the state veterans advisory
committee
thank you mr chairman uh can you hear me
okay very well
very good excuse me thank you mr
chairman
distinguished members of the committee
uh for the record my name is kevin grady
i'm a 23-year resident of hooksett new
hampshire
after a 25 a year career serving in our
air force today i'm here representing
the state veterans advisory committee
and we are a committee of veteran
organizations whose names would be
familiar to you like the american legion
and the veterans of foreign wars i could
i personally represent the air force
association but we're chartered by state
rsa 110 to essentially speak for the
veteran community and one of the things
that we do
is we review all of the bills that are
coming before the legislature
we pick out the ones that we think have
better impact and then we discuss them
and take a position on them and i come
and tell you what our position is
i will tell you that our members
unanimously support this bill
and as i've listened to the conversation
so far this morning
i want to give you just a very brief
history lesson and maybe
something that's going to happen in the
future sometime i hope
uh give some perspective to to the
businesses that you're making on this
particular bill
uh early in the morning of the 19th of
july of 2017
a pipe burst at the manchester va and it
flooded the surgical suite there
and uh at the time governor sununu went
to the va
manchester director whose name was
montoya
and he said al what can i do for you and
and al said
rather than me having just to reschedule
surgeries that are set up for veterans
you know at white river junction or
having these people have to go down to
jamaica plain down in boston
what if i got together with another
hospital here locally
and we sort of extended the va
privileges into that hospital and we'll
let the lawyers figure out where all the
liabilities and everything were
so they partnered agreement with
catholic medical center
and they used their surgical suite while
the va medical center was being repaired
and uh they the governor signed that
executive order and then
we thought well you know what we need to
codify this into the existing rsa
so in the next legislative session in
2018 you had house bill 1273
that sort of allowed for some of the
things you're talking about in this bill
people being supervised
at different places within the va system
but not necessarily in the va
um and i think that this bill goes a
long way to to
try to get all of the things that are
that are included in
all of these scenarios what i want you
to consider for the future
is that that um you know as as
senator sherman said we're all
interested in getting the care that our
veterans
deserve you know and making it easy for
them to get that care
new hampshire is the only state in the
in the union that does not have a full
service va
hospital you know we have a veterans
choice program which was
under was was put together under the
obama administration and then was
renewed under the trump administration
that
allows some of our veterans to get some
services in the local community
and we think that's a great step forward
but ultimately
i don't think we're going to see a
full-service va system
or va medical center in our lifetime
here necessarily in new hampshire
but the idea is if we could find some
some doctors and some pas maybe that
love to ski and want to live in the
north country and we could get an
arrangement with memorial hospital up in
north conway
where they essentially have an office up
there it would be an extension of the va
out in the places
where a veteran wouldn't have to drive
two hours to manchester for something
you know that's that's sort of the
direction that we would ultimately like
all of this to go
and i was not i was i'm not a doctor i
don't play one on tv and i wasn't an
english major at the air force academy
so i will leave the language of all this
stuff up to you folks but our vision for
the future is
you know if we can't get a full va
service hospital here
in new hampshire we would love to be
able to get the care closer to where the
veterans actually are
and if that means assigning people
within the va system who
tend to move around some just like our
members of the military move around some
you know if we can eliminate some of the
the licensing requirement
issues as long as they're part of the va
system writ large
we think that works well and that's all
i wanted to tell you all uh subject to
any of your questions
thank you is it colonel grady yes sir
got it any questions for carol grady
[Music]
i have a feeling we're going to see you
back with some more good legislation
about the va coming
in the years ahead thank you so much for
your testimony colonel
yes sir and now
representative kenner
i thought a friend had her hand up to
ask a question representative
you can do that oh um thank you i i
wanted to ask colonel
grady if it's a short answer
what is the va lacking that it's not a
full
service hospital
i'm not certain of of the exact
requirements for a full service hospital
my guess is that
that we're we're not doing 24 hour a day
operations and our surgical capability
isn't kind of where you'd want it
for a a full service hospital
but i i would need i can if you'd like
representative
another on him i i can get uh i'll ask
that question
to uh our folks at the va and ask them
to get back to you with an answer
thank you i was just curious uh thank
you very much colonel
yes i'm wondering if in the interest of
inter-service cooperation if army major
laflamme
might know that since he's a people
i think he may not be off the call
you know
yeah he's he's off the clock elizabeth
is listed in your hands up
major could you answer that question
about why the va in manchester is not a
full
hospital i can't i i did talk through my
wife's uh she's still streaming this
after i i left the zoo
she's one of the pa students in question
um but we are not
uh beyond our long-term care facility
uh at the clc so it is not a 24 7
operation there are limited surgical
services and does not have an ongoing
inpatient wing
and i it was as stated previously
outside of
new hampshire only hawaii lacks these
capabilities as states so we do have a
limitation
thank you and and as an air force major
through the civil air patrol i thank the
army for that
representative kanark yeah yes thank you
very much i just didn't want to
represent another offhand to be
uh missed so what i did is just for
those of you who have access to your
email
um well mr lafama speaking i was
actually trying to put together the
things that came out
as best i understood linguistically to
make this better
we obviously don't have to wordsmith it
perfectly now but i want to make sure we
have it
accurate before the next time we get
together representative marsh and i
just tried to do an end run and get this
thing in place so that we could execute
today
but clearly we failed on that because we
didn't have some good language on it
so if you are able to open your email
but i'll also just say it verbally
so what i addressed in that line 16
it would instead say
requesting licensure in new hampshire
may be supervised by physicians
not licensed in new hampshire provided
they possess a current license
in good standing in their respective
state or
territory of the u.s that way we have
taken care of not excluding new
hampshire
physicians we've taken care of not
excluding somebody from puerto rico um
and we're not discussing uh you know
where the physician is from but
simply the licensure then on line
22 uh i changed that
to saying although 21 22 uh offering
services to the state of new hampshire
and out-of-state
licensed physicians accepting
supervisory
uh responsibility in other words not
worrying about
you know just that they're from
out-of-state but where they're licensed
from
i just need feedback from people as
whether that satisfies the requirements
of the discussion we had
and i do apologize i will do this later
because i think he's off the call
to um senator sherman for not sending
him this draft amendment that would have
been smarter but i didn't
the other questions though that come up
are that question that
representative woods brought up about
did we suspend all regulations and rules
and should we insert a phrase just
saying
new hampshire state licenses line seven
new hampshire state licensure laws rules
and regulations regarding licensure and
supervision for physician assistance
inserting the words regarding life
insurance supervision to make sure
that we're not suspending every rule for
them
the last one i guess would be what came
up then in that discussion about that
not all
care is at a licensed facility
and should we strike the language at
licensed medical facilities just if it's
coordinated through the va
so if people could give me some quick
feedback on that then
uh i will with bill marsh
drafts another amendment but i want
feedback from people
do we need that change in line seven
that representative woods said
and again the changes i put in red i did
not put
the change from the conversation with
representative gay
and mr laflamme because i was composing
this as that went on
and sent it and did not get that into
there so first
and represented woodstock on line seven
do we need to put a restriction on what
the
um suspension has to do with or is it
or do you think it was already obvious
it doesn't hurt to me it doesn't hurt if
it's obvious
to adding okay by the word but i think
it's a good concept
sometimes fair enough and then line 11
shall we uh strike their language at
licensed medical facilities outside of
the manchester vamc
just because then that if you're doing
home care that is not being excluded
jerry represents um i think we should
be careful because there needs to be
some language in there
to ensure that the relationship between
the facility does exist with the va
under contract of some capacity it does
a
relatively large the other question i'd
say as long as i went through
amendment suggestions the other issue
which didn't
raise before if you're an out of country
physician
or pa and you prescribe in new hampshire
in new hampshire we cannot fill the
prescription at the pharmacy
we'll have to go to the va because we're
only
allowed to fill a prescription by a
licensed physician or pa
within the confines of the us
fair enough as long as again in this
case all we're doing is changing that
issue about the supervising
physician they already have the out of
state uh pas there
so i don't know it's out of country as
long as the outer country's taken out of
it completely
oh well that's good but that's gone
anyway all right but the other one
though is i'd rather be sure that we
have some sort of
restriction or we tend to have
a contractual relationship between the
va system and whatever
the pa is overseeing or working in well
the language would still be there that
would say
offering medical services coordinated
through the va
so it would have to be coordinated
through them there'd have to be a
relationship
that language would be still there just
the
that's line 10 it would just take out
line 11 that talks about
at licensed medical facilities
i think that still worked for you i i
think the word coordinated is kind of
broad
um i think it could be okay but i think
again back to the same thing where it's
obvious is that
there is a contractual relationship
because if the patient
does go to that facility is they're
really trying to do is they're coming
under the hospice of the va
system and that should be done through a
contract not just the fact that they're
coordinated so
the patient is getting the same level of
care and services
that they would have in the va system
itself if they're outside of it
so that only can be done we only can
ensure that if there's a contractual
relationship between the va system and
the facility
can we hear from the lawyer
well i've got a few more in the queue
here thank you representative merchant
chair recognizes representative nelson
unhuge i'm muted
there we go sorry about that line 18 it
says territory
united states what is district of
columbia considered
i just looked it up it's a territory
thank
thank you joe
anything else representative nelson
thank you that's it okay representative
weber
thank you mr chairman i was going to
suggest
online 10 instead of saying
coordinated through if we perhaps used
the words
offered by because that
implies that it's coming from the va
um and i think it
might have a slightly stronger nexus
uh for the concerns that
uh were raised i think it was by
representative woods but maybe it was by
representative merchant
i think the
issue of the suspension of the laws
rules and regulations having been
in the original language which we have
operated under for years and years and
years
is is not so much of a concern to me but
i think
having the qualifier in there is
probably
better practice because we want to make
sure we're saying what exactly
what we're giving guidance about but
make sure that
is vetted really
carefully with the practitioners from
the va to ensure we're not restricting
something else that they actually need
to do
so those are my kind yeah may i quickly
speak to that though that language
it was not there for a long time that
was put in under the emergency order
there's 328 d2a
328 d2 was what was initially in there
and did not have the things about the
suspension
um the the language about suspension all
had to do with the emergency order
uh because of covid so that's the thing
i'm concerned about is it might have
been some sloppy drafting
when it was put together uh back last
year clarification
as as i'm looking at this oh maybe
because i'm looking at the amendment let
me look at the original
um as i as i look at both the amendment
and the original bill it seems to be
indicating that the language on lines
seven and eight were part of the
original statute
not yes but it's part of the original
statute 328 d2a that was put in place by
executive order
emergency order put a statute in place
by
executive order well then what is all
this there's a statute or it's not
so i'll go and look it up and see what
it says yeah take a look because it has
this large preamble of all the executive
orders
um that led to it and they and it's why
it's labeled d2a but
i appreciate that it's not by statute
but somehow it got in
in response so i think that has only
been there it was effective june
14 2018 though so i'm i'm getting more
confused as i say so i don't know the
answer
representative weber i'll look at the
underlying statute and we can discuss
more great thank you i'd appreciate that
i understand and i will run this
i'll run this final language by
representing weber and
obviously by mr laflamme uh to make sure
that it's
satisfying the va needs i've read all
the other stuff
by mr laflamme uh before representing
marsh and i put this together
okay what about the wording though when
i the wording that i put in to try to
solve this thorny thing about
out of state and all that stuff does are
people okay with that currently
i have fewer words representative gay
for fewer words
okay line 17 in the amendment
uh well starting 16 may be supervised by
physicians
skip from other states provided they
just say but may be supervised by
physicians
who possess a current license in good
standing
in their respective state or u.s
territory
and there's one other one other word
word change i'm suggesting
line 10 coordinate okay currently says
coordinated
through the veterans administration
medical okay
instead of coordinated how about
administered by
the va or provided by
the va
on that one
okay
representative kenner you ready for
another question or
well i i i think the question about con
coordinated through offered through
or whatever representative gay just came
up with i i would that one i would not
want to defer to
representative weber who of who offered
that phrase offered through as to what
makes the most legal since she is our
token uh lawyer on the on the
team we have uh lawyers as well at ols
um yeah i know but i know this for the
first time
they're not us okay um i'm going to
suggest we
move towards wrapping up what has become
a work session
um and i'm going to call the people i
have on my list
and then close the hearing
become work session awaiting good work
and because the first bill we heard um
means we've got to come back then we'll
come back for this one as well
probably a couple of weeks um
representative shapiro
yes not wanting to be wrong i once again
googled ms washington d.c and territory
and um it is clear that some people
think it is and some people think it
isn't
and so i would probably just bring that
up with the people from
um ols and have that defer to them for
language that would be inclusive
thank you representative weber
i just wanted to say that i looked up
section
328 d colon 2a and
when you look at it there's a huge chunk
of language referring to emergency
orders
but that's just telling you that you
need to go and look at those emergency
orders and see what the emergency orders
say
because they do in fact modify the
existing language
but the existing language says new
hampshire state licensure laws rules and
regulations are hereby suspended
and it has said that since uh 2018 which
is when
the initial language was passed i still
don't have a problem clarifying it
further
thank you representative folsom
oh well i was just um sorry i was
going off of what uh representative
weber said in representative gay
and the confusion over the coordinated
truth
i would agree with weber and because
if you notice everywhere else like in
line 8
and line 15 they use the word offering
and if we stick with the word offer i
think it it provides
a continuity and a consistency
thank you and representative
merchants
my question was answered thank you thank
you okay
anything further uh i would suggest
individuals may call representative
kenner
we've uh done an awful lot of work on
about 26 lines so with that i am closing
the hearing from work
session on uh senate bill 120
as amended i'm not closing the hearing
yet i have a few things from me
and then we have something from
representative snow
the anyway just a quick thing this room
is reminiscent of our one hour on
shell and may last year it was wonderful
thank you for all your help
we have to do this to make the uh
seven new people to the committee um
share a history with us
um all right quick question uh no we're
finished on this
uh you can call representative canuck if
you wish your representative
march um we have
five retained bills
um at present we may wind up with
another one but right now we have five
103. um uh you may wish to write the
numbers down
so you can look them up 103 an act
establishing a dental
benefit under the state medicaid program
247 an act relative to treatment
alternatives to opioids that number
again
the second one was two four seven
the third one is three one four
an act relative to homestead food
operation licensure
house bill 602
reimbursements for telemedicine
in house bill 604 an act expanding the
new hampshire vaccine association
to include adult vaccines we have these
five retained
i know i still have the list of people
who wish to be
on mental health bills versus
other bills but if anyone was
interested in saying you would like to
be on any of these
i'll accept those emails and
try to jiggle together some work
sessions
[Music]
a couple of months from now i also want
to point out
and actually a couple of committee
chairs have
pointed this out to me under
gosh you guys sure do have a lot on
consent
or 19 to 2. and i think that is because
of the procedure that just sort of
evolved into existence of
a republican grabbing a democrat after a
hearing
and saying you know i think we can bring
together good points you have and good
points we have and
have something that isn't maybe a
compromise but maybe more
comprehensively good
and you brought that amendment to an
exact session and
all of this or most of us agreed
and i think that's why it's that process
and so
on these um retain bills when there'll
be work sessions on them
and on the two bills we looked at today
senate bill 45 and senate bill 120.
um i i think this is um at the risk of
being a poli-sci
professor this is
a lesson in how we get things done
i certainly have some non-negotiables i
have ideology
i have certain moral tenants
and i'll stick to them
but most of the bills we have are not
that or not that to a great
degree or to a degree where my views and
the views of others
can be accommodated if we work for it
and the idea of let's work towards that
means
as teddy roosevelt said the hero is the
one who makes mistakes but is engaged in
the process
and not sits on the sideline so as we go
forward i'd love to see more bills
as many as possible knowing there's a
few that will not be this the more
that we can come out with a happy
agreement
the better i think we've enjoyed that
um and i think that's something that we
can
more intentionally work towards
so i'll be uh happy to receive
your uh suggestions as to which
of these bills work sessions you'd be
like to
like to be on and i'll let you know but
don't expect it for a couple of months
part of that is we have to wait to make
sure there's enough technical
staff available because work sessions
are public events now
how many people what's that how many
people do you want to put on these i
don't know yet
don't know yet i mean if you only have a
few you don't get all the
possible points if you have too many it
becomes unwieldy don't know yet
less than half but still now
representative snow
thank you very much one other question
is i don't think i have the most recent
amendment to 120.
do we have any printed copies of the one
we was actually working on
the one we were working off um part of
the time was 1107.
that's not the one i had okay there's
1107.
and uh that that's right with the other
one that i sent out was just something i
was doing as a little work product as we
were working so people could see it in
writing
so can i send it in the email to our
committee
but don't worry it's not an official
amendment yet that's what we'll work on
thank you very much and now the the bill
that yes
one of the concerns i have is a bill
that we passed in the last session
it was a very brief bill it was two
paragraphs long
it was very simple bill it simply looked
at medicaid in and out
which is a service that's provided to
individuals whose income is too high
to qualify for medicaid but they have
ongoing medical expenses that are so
high that they couldn't possibly
meet those obligations with their income
so it's simply there's a law that was
passed 30 years ago that said
if that income is if they spend down
to what was determined to be the poverty
level all
medical expenses beyond that are going
to be covered by medicaid
that's you have to do that each month
and so forth but it does work
however as you probably aware the cost
of living has gone up somewhat in the
last 30 years
so what we did was we tried to modify
what that
base was going to be that the spend down
had to come down to before they
qualified and that passed this committee
i think it was
20 to nothing and past the senate
senator sherman was very involved in
that i was like is he still on
or did he go up
oh okay see part of what i was doing as
long as we had him
as a captive audience i was going to
check because i've got to call him about
this
and it was signed by the governor now it
got confusing because house bill
1639 was the number
it was two paragraphs long when i wrote
it when it was finally passed in the
house the title was changed from
medicaid
and out to health care to health care
concerns or something like that
and it became 39 pages and it was
what was euphemistically called a
christmas tree bill
remember because of all the
complications going on in this
in the senate but it did pass was signed
by the governor
and currently the department of health
and human services is under an
obligation to meet these new guidelines
because we
passed that law and it was signed into
law
unfortunately the governor did not
include any funds
to increase the money that was available
in the minute and uh when i spoke with
uh representative edwards oh i didn't
speak personally
but when they made the report i asked
the question and they included any money
to fund that
he didn't seem to be aware that that was
something that needed to be done so it
was not included
in division three's budget
so um influenced the senate
to cooperate some number what that
number is is a
mystery to me it's very confusing
because we don't know who's going to
qualify to go in we'll no longer have to
do
you know but some people now will fall
under the new
guideline and they'll go into the
regular managed care campground
and others so it's you know the
the uh the fiscal note was an absolute
nightmare
and department didn't really know how to
figure out what it was going to be
i've made some calls and got a call back
yesterday and then able to take it
another zoom call but uh tim
timothy is tim lippman the head of
medicaid
i asked if he could be of any assistance
to us to try to figure out i said
we need some kind of a number to at
least be included
in house bill in the budget
either hospital too
so that this doesn't get off the ground
because as you know there were a number
of cuts
to the department of health and human
services they lost a number of positions
so they don't have a lot of flexibility
to suddenly stop funding this at an
additional level
especially if we don't have any idea
what we're asking for so
i'm going to call senator sherman and
senator
uh roosevelt uh who are both on the
health committee
and i think of any of the others of you
this was a bill that was very important
to this committee
i think and it makes common sense i mean
this
isn't this affects a lot of people with
mental illness but it also affects
people
who are on dialysis or have other
ongoing medical expenses
it can be pretty overwhelming so i think
it's a pretty important bill and i hope
that whatever we can do
just to say sorry it was an oversight
this was never included in the budget we
need to find a way
to now include something from the budget
so they uh
because they are obligated to know me
it's been signed into law you can't
go back to the old way
senator snow you've picked a tremendous
time to find
the unmute this is great
i i hope that you will keep us all in
the committee
looped in as to when you talk to mr
lippman and so on and so forth
because i think this um there may be
time to talk
to the senate in terms of their budget
now that we sent it to them
and senator geider who was here before
uh is
um on that budget thing so
he'd like to know i'm sure our alumni on
in the senate uh rep senator sherman and
rosenwald
i'm sure would be very interested so you
send us what
we need to know and you make suggestions
on how we can help
what i was really hoping for today is
that he'd still be on so
he's trying to get through it these guys
right now on the phone
and you know i don't know about you i
don't know if you get as many emails as
i did
yeah i'm certainly sending an email you
kind of wonder
i'm texting yeah i would too thank you
so much for that
i'm sorry that was not an official i
just dropped this letter
representative weber
sorry i i think that the the the ending
remarks took care of what i was gonna
say i mean the
the only thing that need that can help
particularly right now is getting in
touch with the senators
on the finance committee in the senate
uh
immediately if not sooner and and making
sure they're aware because the
department is under an obligation to
fund it whether it's in the budget
or not and if they're under an
obligation to fund it then that means
more funds have to come from somewhere
else uh and i'm also
going to apologize to the committee for
having
been so slow at muting and unmuting i
made a terrible experiment last night
in that i decided to try
uh glue on fingernails for the first
time
by 68 years and i am here to tell you
that i have glued my own fingernails to
my
skin and in at least one
case i have glued not one but two
fingernails on top of my own fingernails
and i should perhaps have read the
instructions because
i gather i'm now going to have to just
wait for the uh
glue to loosen of its own accord
i can't actually
operate in in in the ways that i used to
and i know people can do it because i've
seen them do it so i need to adapt but
representative webber i have two
responses to that number one i know a
retired hand search and he's really good
and secondly if i ever was tempted to
try glue on fingernails
um you have convinced me it's a bad idea
let's see how
well thank you all and now the official
gavel drop
this ends the hearing for
the house committee health human
services and elderly affairs
and you're going to notice we'll
probably have an exec session in a
couple of weeks
so and i'll keep the cards and letters
coming
as a ps the good news is
that those people who should qualify by
the law
are entitled to the benefits it's a
courtesy to tell the budget that they
need to expect it
well yeah
and who's